Okay.
One of the big concepts in evolutionary medicine,
uh,
probably almost as important as trade off is the concept of mismatch.
The key thing going on with mismatch is the fact that rates are different rates
of different processes can be fast or slow.
Okay.
There are important consequences of the fact that we humans have constructed our
own ecological niches.
This has produced diseases of mismatch.
There are different kinds of environmental change that are going on that
produced mismatches.
Yeah.
And some of these are effecting the Microbiota in the human body and that has
knock on consequences for our health and disease.
So the underlying idea here is that adaptation is rarely precise and it is often
leggings.
So biology is often lagging behind environmental change because genetic change
takes time.
Selection is only producing a really good match of organisms to environment when
it's acting for a long time in a stable environment,
in a population without much gene flow.
Well that doesn't happen very often.
Okay.
If the environment changes,
some of the phenotypic states and some of the genetic variation that produces
them will be mismatched until selection can catch up.
Well selection may never catch up.
Okay.
And so mismatched describes the situation in which there's both a poor fit,
a phenotype to environment,
and it also means that selection is acting to improve that fit.
So in a way,
anytime a person uses the word mismatch,
you can think,
oh,
it's an indication that natural selection is going on in that population.
Yeah.
Now what about relative rates?
Cultural change has become a very potent source of mismatch because cultural
change is so much more rapid than biological change.
Yeah.
We continue to evolve biologically,
but biological changes occurring on a chip on a scale of hundreds of
generations.
Cultural Change occurs on a scale of one generation or even less.
Culture is likely to continue to outpace biology and biology is likely to
continue to struggle to keep up with it.
So mismatch is going to remain an important element of our condition for the
foreseeable future.
No humans have been constructing the world that they live in.
We've done that with agriculture,
urbanization,
the medical system,
air and water pollution,
and with glide climate change.
So they're on many different scales.
We've been changing our environment.
This has resulted in less exposure to parasites,
pathogens and symbiotes.
More exposure to artificial light,
profound changes in our diet,
a more sedentary lifestyle,
less temperature fluctuation,
and much more salt,
sugar,
alcohol,
tobacco,
and other addictive drugs available in our environment.
The environmental changes are complex and their biological effects are usually
mediated by genotype,
by environment interaction,
so simple explanations are often going to mislead.
Here are some of the mismatch diseases.
I won't read through all of them.
You can look them up in the book.
These are things like acne,
anxiety,
asthma,
Bunyan's,
tooth cavities,
chronic constipation,
coronary heart disease,
Crohn's disease,
diaper rash,
emphysema,
flat feet,
gout,
polycystic ovarian syndrome,
scurvy,
stomach ulcers.
These are all important kinds of conditions associated with mismatch.
You can think of that as being dis evolution.
Now there are different kinds of environmental change and just because we're
constructing our environment,
that doesn't mean we can predict the results because many of the things that we
do have surprising consequences,
individual decisions that we make accumulate to have population level
consequences and these population consequences are hard to anticipate.
For example,
the fact that we are generating climate change through our consumption and
reproductive behavior was not at all clear and that was a hard thing to
anticipate.
Emerging diseases are often unpleasant surprises that come from our habitat
destruction in our population expansion,
our niche construction has particularly affected our own microbiota.
So what are some of the roles of the Microbiota in human health?
Our interactions depended in part on things going on in intestines,
skin,
upper respiratory tract and genital urinary tract where Commensal Microbiota are
inducing the development of the immune and the gastrointestinal systems in.
In infants,
they're helping to maintain normal immune functions.
In all of these tissues,
they,
in our gut,
they synthesize some of the vitamins that are essential.
They mediate the digestion of fats and carbohydrates,
so they have a role to play in obesity.
And when their function is disrupted by modern environments,
that is one of the major reasons that we become mismatched.
So to summarize in this introduction,
mismatched describes both a poor fit of organisms to the environment and
selection that is acting to improve that fit.
Okay.
Many of the current mismatches result from the inability of biology to change as
fast as culture changes.
Yeah.
Recent changes include less exposure to microorganisms,
more artificial light,
better temperature controlled housing,
profound changes in Diet,
less physical activity,
and more exposure to addictive drugs.
Okay.
Mismatch might be contributing to at least 50 diseases and other health issues,
and many of these issues are related to changes in the Microbiota.